pues el día de hoy les voy a hablar un
poco sobre el espacio que tenemos los
jóvenes aquí en los proyectos sociales
son ilustraciones por 936 bueno
hoy esta charla porque pues hay muchos
comentarios de si de ahí estaría padre
que los jóvenes hicieran algo ahí es que
nada están con el celular y pues también
hay que tomar estos signos como pues la
no participación también es un signo
entonces pues a veces se puede
considerar que este es como un lugar es
adulto céntrico y futuro fóbico adulto
sentí como porque somos tomados en
cuenta a veces formalmente la ley a
partir de los 18 años y pues eso deja
como de lado muchos de los proyectos que
iguales pueden tener como los niños o la
bandita un poco más joven que 18
y pues porque tenemos que vestir de
ciertas maneras para poder como venir y
dar algún mensaje que sea como valioso
tal vez como ganarnos ese lugar por
medio de un título o cosas así y pues
esto deja fuera pues también a muchas
personas y futuro fólico porque por un
lado pues dicen que el futuro es como de
nosotros de los jóvenes y pues a veces
la hora de la hora pues puede ser común
si complicado
de 6
entonces de ser como algo así super
padre
nosotros somos el futuro puede ser que
muchas veces estén como dejando toda esa
comida para nosotros y se siente así
entonces cuando hablamos de
oportunidades para para
probar que nosotros podemos nada más es
por medio de concursos que pues es algo
muy limitante porque solo algunos entran
y sólo como uno o dos o tres ganan y
pues esto hace que muchas ideas queden
fuera y los espacios pues a veces suelen
ser como en un salón de clases de voy a
presentar una solución a un problema
real pero esto no se va a implementar
entonces pues pues eso hace genera
apatía genera que no queramos participar
porque al final de cuentas las las
soluciones que estamos ofreciendo no van
a hacer pues tomadas en cuenta en un
espacio real solo imaginario y entonces
pues debemos de saber si el futuro es de
nosotros entonces
[Música]
la confianza donde quieres
si sólo se ofrecen en este tipo de
espacios entonces quería decir que la
chaviza tiene la capacidad de
involucrarse que hay que no
necesariamente hay que ser para empezar
a hacer cosas
entonces qué tal si podemos hacer un
mejor futuro no ustedes sino nosotros el
futuro sin empezar desde ya juntos y
ahora les voy a hablar un poco sobre
voluntariado coyuntural
que es pues voluntariado que hace
sensibles a las personas sensibilizar
sobre problemáticas reales igual y en
otro tipo de planos realidades y es
importante pues conocer las diferentes
problemáticas que hay no y bali no
estamos enamoradas de una en particular
pero sabemos este que hay por eso es
importante conocer y esto es para
sensibilizar es muy valioso el
voluntariado porque pues hace que esto
suceda
sentir bonita en el corazón y darnos
cuenta de que nos importan otras
personas
entonces el voluntariado puede ser el
primer paso hacia un proyecto social
pertinente y todo paso es importante y
necesario
y ahora los proyectos sociales
pertinentes tratan sobre colaborar
tratan sobre construir largo plazo y
hacerlo juntos o sea verlos a los ojos e
iguale un voluntariado es es más pues
ayudar a levantar y esto ya estamos
hablando de iguales
una frase silla cursi
y pues ahora les quiero hablar un
poquito de mi historia para que sepan
que pues si se fue pues mi mamá y se le
agradezco mucho ella empezó a llevarme a
voluntariados y este tipo de cosas desde
muy muy pequeña
entonces éste pues con ella aprendí que
que no todo el mundo tiene como las
mismas oportunidades y que no todo el
mundo puede este pues jugar
[Música]
situaciones así como bastante
contrastantes
y esto fue generando en mí como esta
empatía y este gusto por conectarme con
otras personas que igual
[Música]
y después estuve en el instituto en
esandi en donde ahí pues empezamos a
practicar un poco esta parte de los
proyectos hacia nuestra propia comunidad
como hacia donde nosotros estábamos que
podíamos mejorar de eso y ahí están
muchos un equipo de maestros que son
increíbles porque es un es un modelo
socio constructivista que lo que hace es
escogemos un proyecto que queramos
alguna causa y con eso todos los en las
materias van vinculadas a ese proyecto
entonces nos enseñan a cómo podemos
aplicar las cosas mejorando nuestro
entorno al mismo tiempo
y pues bueno entre a prepa y las cosas
son muy diferentes aquí este pues había
como resistencia hacia hacia las mejoras
como significativas éste había más como
este plan d
sí sí y en prepa pues un día estaba por
ahí
un buen día en mi papá no me puedo
recoger de la escuela entonces me tocó
irme aquí y yo vivo en santa catarina
entonces estaba estaba caminando por ahí
y pues me gusta ser el piso porque pues
no sé es tan bonito y de repente estoy
así caminando y de repente veo como
adoquín y todo
y así como muy coqueto todo de repente
volteo y está como un bachecito por aquí
[Música]
y como el pavimento un poco más
descuidado y entonces volteo y veo esto
esto es donde yo estaba caminando y esto
fue con lo que me topé entonces se me
hizo como muy novedoso porque tan
diferente entonces voltea para allá y
veía como el sol del atardecer y así
todo bien bonito de repente así ay qué
extraño que estén cómo andan cerquita y
entonces pues me quedé con esto un
ratillo y como unos días después asistía
a un ánfora que se llamaba proyecto cero
un congreso en donde el mensaje era que
si ya sabes con qué algo que intrigó en
el corazón como a mí con la situación
anterior entonces debes de preguntar qué
hacer y hacer eso no llegar a decir a
por qué parte yo ya no de seguro aquí lo
que se necesita es pintar para que sea
más bonita entonces yo ya y fácil como
no tienes que preguntarme
y entonces pues va a ser que a la
colonia que después supe que se llama
jesús m garza y así no sea llegué y
pregunte qué
que quien fue a hablar conmigo y
entonces me dirigieron a una señora que
se llama seña silvia y ella me contó que
lo que necesitaban ahí era
regularización y yo no tenía idea de lo
que significa la regularización después
no explicaron que era cómo obtener los
papeles para tu propiedad
y yo tampoco sabía que necesitabas
papeles para tener tus propiedades pero
bueno entonces este después de ahí la
señora si la represento a la señora
martha y así se fue armando como la
bolita de vecinos y de repente estamos
en una junta vecinal y todo mundo está
hablando de quejas y quejas y cosas que
habían hecho y que no se ha solucionado
y de repente entre más teníamos juntas
empezaban a salir un poco más como de
propuestas y de soluciones para saber ok
que ya está aquí están las quejas ahora
sí que vamos a hacer al respecto no
entonces ellos decían no pues podemos
hacer esto y podemos hacer tal cosa sí
y pues eran temas que yo realmente pues
no conocía bien entonces decidí ponerme
a llamar
porque este es el celular que yo tengo
y pues bueno entonces empecé a hablar
con la vecino y con el narval y con
celina y con éste con emilio y así y me
decían todos que pues tenía que ser sí
pero yo me senté haciendo me seguía
sintiendo pues bastante
no no cualificada para esto y entonces
eso es una junta de final y luego conocí
a somos nosotros que es un colectivo de
participación ciudadana formado por
puros chavos y en ese momento yo creo
que habrán tenido como 19 algo así
no son todos estudiantes de diferentes
carreras
i
los invito a la colonia y deciden
trabajar allí también ellos voy a
trabajar en otra colonia y pues no sé
cómo que hicimos un buen
un buen trabajo y empezamos a trabajar
como más de cerca con los vecinos en
temas de transporte que ahorita lo va a
explicar y naturalmente con la
regularización que era como la necesidad
más sentida y después me entero de que
hay una
el programa de becas que se van a formar
para transformar el audio y pues esto
pasó muy rápido porque yo me enteré que
me gusta sociología pero no sabía que la
sociología y no sabía dónde estudiar ese
así entonces en
pues gracias a la jesús m garza que pude
encontrar como lo que realmente amigo
ocasión y por lo cual la tía siempre y
pues entré a este programa que me dio la
oportunidad de seguir estudiando y de
es llevar como un acompañamiento
adecuado para este proyecto
y después pues éste se lo de de la
colonia que del proyecto
también hay cuestiones que considero
importante para hacer un proyecto social
pertinente que son estas entonces
y somos nosotros en colaboración con el
consejo de vecinos tratamos estas cosas
la horizontal ideal que es
como como hay proyectos en los que son
así como el presidente y el tesorero se
presta un poco más como para este tipo
de jerarquías que no haya tanta
discusión entonces en este proyecto
todas las voces de todos los vecinos son
aceptadas y del colectivo son aceptadas
entonces se presta como para este
diálogo es una manera como de evitar a
mérito gracias y cuestiones de egos y
así entonces ha funcionado bonito
y luego él lo interdisciplinario pues
somos de diferentes disciplinas hay dos
arquitecturas en dos de relaciones
internacionales
en recursos humanos ingeniería en
desarrollo sustentable y energía
sociología y pues eso ha funcionado bien
porque como tenemos todos estos
diferentes puntos de vista desde la
academia pues es fructífero
lo colaborativo que significa poner como
adelante está esta cuestión de pues
vamos a a como piececitas en un
rompecabezas nada de ello por mi cuenta
y voy a echarme a todo mundo encima es
idónea
es más bien buscar este espacio de
diálogo y ver en qué manera podemos
colaborar para todos salir adelante al
mismo tiempo
es intergeneracional porque la persona
como más rejilla de el proyecto tiene
con 80 y 82 años y pues la persona más
joven dejó como 19 entonces pues eso
hace las cosas muy padres porque
entonces tenemos todo este como un marco
de referencia de personas que han vivido
ahí en la colonia como por mucho tiempo
y de asesores que han trabajado 30 años
en otros proyectos y pues personas que
vamos iniciando a que pues tal vez
tengamos como mil mil preguntas
y de acompañamiento porque se trata más
de ir a imponer es más de ir a acompañar
en este proceso de sostenibilidad
entonces el comité de vecinos están las
instituciones los estudiantes y los
adultos más grandes que son los asesores
entonces puntitos para tomar en cuenta
sería puedes valorar la historia y
experiencia previa escuchando antes de
decidir o de decir qué es lo que se debe
hacer en un proyecto pensar si es
necesario el cambio porque se habla
mucho de este cambio que necesitamos
cambiar aristas no necesitamos cambiar a
veces nada más necesitamos retomar o
volver a plantear cosas pero no es
necesario cambiar siempre innovar si
está sobrevalorado es
y pensarse así sin tener claro la
finalidad de enamorarse de los medios
tal vez hay algo que te guste mucho
hacer pero pues hay ocasiones en las que
necesitamos como
realmente decir esto va con mi objetivo
o es más como por show
y colaborar e interconectar hacer
alianzas por encima de protagonismos o
por querer la llevar solo
entonces pues es una invitación a
involucrar a los niños a sensibilizarse
y bueno a que se sensibilicen que
conozcan sobre las problemáticas que hay
que usen el camión que caminen que estén
vayan a hospitales que no se hagan las
cosas de ellas para sensibilizarse que
confíen en los jóvenes porque ha habido
como muchos conflictos en los que pues
es difícil entrar y decir ay tome en
serio y traigo toda esta propuesta y qué
tal si colaboramos pero es así como hay
sin niños
a la vuelta joven y bueno pues observar
que hay a nuestro alrededor y preguntar
si es justo
si no pues qué puedo hacer al respecto
entonces siempre se pueden hacer cosas
al respecto
pues como xavi ksas ser puentes y ser
conectores entre personas sea la jesus m
garza igual estaba como por ahí y pues
otras instancias y otras instituciones
están por allá y nosotros estamos como
tratando de ese sitio de conectarnos
y puedes cuestionarnos la manera en la
que me acerco a colaborar es la
apropiada como le puedo hacer y pues no
sé si ustedes han hablado con personas
pero pues para hablar se necesitan dos
entonces es importante estar como
siempre receptivos y siempre comunicando
y pues bueno gracias